on se voir mes amis gros ours s'est fait
très beau aujourd'hui oui vous ne
trouvez pas il est vraiment de plus en
plus coquets vers ce que le petit louis
murat belles vont faire mon portrait a
tout de suite patron a tout de suite
gros morceau alors vous aussi les petits
amis prenez un crayon et une feuille de
papier et fait un beau dessin de gros
source
tu vois j'ai décret de toutes les
couleurs et blanches des jaunes et
rouges des marrons et moi je vais faire
une belle photo rogeau jours nous allons
faire votre portrait
elle a du mal à tout dit m la mêlée a
publié pour la photo ce sera mieux
comme lundi dont moi j'ai besoin d'une
loi droit qui aiment plusieurs droits
droit moi j'aime mieux droit quasiment
pas moi si j'ai les bras cette oreille
là un petit peu plus rond comme
lancement voilà la plus les yeux des
grands cils
[Musique]
on est jeune on m'offre la la comme ça
c'est pas mal encore un petit peu de
rouge sur le nez les gantois toi ce
matin dopage peu plus d'un an au au oui
oh oh c'est fatigant 6 au bout ça y est
ça va sûrement est une belle photo tu
peux te mettre debout je veux en faire
une autre de boucles non non non non moi
j'ai pas fini mon portrait en couleur
oui mais toi de boudin noir je fais
juste une photo du trace one moi je te
dis que j'ai pas fini de sa monte entre
en couleurs mais je veux rester debout
nous mêmes les enfers ces dangers qui
déboule j'ai dit ah sinon bonjour
l'icône ils tous des civils
[Musique]
il était tôt merci patron allez les
enfants on lit et les portraits j'en
referai plus j'ai compris si grand que
partout où on verra on verra à l'eau
dans mes vite
puis le d'ornement dit tu sais vous
voulez jouer je sais je sais on lui on
lui mettait tout déchirer il est fâché
ouais au papy ou soit tu lui et de
mirabel
[Musique]
décidément petit louis et mirabel sont
deux petits diables alors mon pauvre
nounou mon joli petit col une long tout
déchirer si je ne t'avais pas appelé
je crois bien qu'il aurait mis toi aussi
en morceaux comme lui et vous les petits
enfants quand vous faites des portraits
j'espère que vous n'êtes plus sage que
p'tit louis et mirabel maintenant allez
vite vous coucher et faites de beaux
rêves
bonne nuit
dany boon hui
e
[Musique]